Mui Mui.
Go ahead, Ninja Manja-sama!
Hello, hello, hello, hello, hello, hello.
Hello, hello, hello, hello.
Welcome in.
Hi.
Howdy, dody.
Hello, welcome back to Limbo.
Oh.
Oh, you shall.
prevail today, hopefully.
Hopefully!
Hi, Minikiri.
Hello!
My Kamiyoshi.
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
Hope you are feeling okay?
Guys, I got hit with the double whammy.
The double whammy, that is, head hort, tummy hort.
Being a ghost is so terrible.
It's just...
I'm just in the purgatory of never ending uh pain it's so
overrated people think oh my gosh you're dead you're not
gonna you're not gonna feel anything what do you think being
a ghost is huh what do you think being a ghost is
anyway so thank you i i uh vaude watchers probably uh they
don't know but i took an extra woke up.
I just woke up from a nap.
Is it because you died of tummy hort?
I died of everything hort.
I died of heart break maybe.
Heart hort.
Head hort.
You ate too much pizza yesterday, didn't you?
Pizza would never betray me like that.
What are you talking about?
Pizza?
A comfort food.
Pizza would never do that to me.
What are you talking about?
Oh my god.
Sakana!
What the hell are you doing here?
Well, I also had tech issues right before the stream.
And what had happened was...
I, um, I, I, I, I opened up the game.
So I play this game on a separate computer, right?
I have a dual stream setup, so fancy.
But, um, I opened it and it, for some reason, even though I
had my Steam in, uh, offline or whatever, it was like, do
you want to remote play this game?
And I was like, you know what, I'll be honest.
and I just clicked okay I didn't read it all and I clicked
okay and then it started like desktop sharing to from from
my current computer but it was showing up through like the
through through the OBS so it was very confusing and I
didn't know how to get out of it And I was like, what's
going on?
And a classic, spamming okay until it works.
That's truly what I did.
I was like, open the game, open the game.
I don't care.
Open the game.
And it was like doing that thing where if I like move the
window in a certain way, it would do like an endless thing.
like like you know hall of mirrors type type situation with
my window and i was like i don't know how to get out of this
so i am sleepy and i don't remember the controls to this
game i also was scared i was like oh my gosh what if because
i did it in offline it like didn't save anything wants to
save to the cloud but if it's offline then will it save and
I was like stressing but I see resume so hopefully we're
okay I think we're okay not reading side effect of too many
audiobooks hey hey hey wait a second not reading is how the
brickster escapes jail so true pizzazz pizza it's all the
same right so let's make sure resume gets us okay last i
remember we were in a pretty tricky situation i believe we
were about to do a quite the puzzle so brickster mentioned
brickster that's my oshi actually no that guy is too smart
and the police in that in lego island town were too dumb
You know the Brickster Should go do a heist at the Louvre
Maybe he wouldn't get away I mean, wait I mean, maybe he
would get away
We need more heists, I think I think we need more Heists You
guys agree?
We need a little bit Less stupid crimes More heists that are
exciting if you steal a painting.
It's my birthday, Roxas!
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you!
Agreed.
So true.
Yeah!
Next you're gonna wanna steal the moon.
What am I?
A minion?
Minto becomes the Phantom Thief.
Yeah, we see more like your nemesis.
How much pizzazz needed to sacrifice to catch him?
How much?
The port!
Yeah, how many pizzas did we have to throw at him?
Man.
Anyway, I do have things that I gotta do later.
I will be at a maid cafe for many hours.
Until like 2 a.m.
my time.
game baby okay oh that sounds like a dream i will be at a
maid cafe for two hours or i mean two until 2 a.m whoa
that's crazy me too no way well wouldn't it be so crazy if i
like saw you wouldn't that be like so wild wouldn't that be
like the craziest thing okay what was this pull the lava
Oh my gosh.
Learning a game like this is going to be tricky.
We're relearning, I'd say.
Gotta go do family stuff.
Have fun!
I think I need to get up there.
There's like a lever.
That lever there, no?
So I think I need to get to this lever up here.
I'm not quite sure yet.
But what would it have to do with...
Oh.
I'm too small.
I'm too small still.
We know.
You don't know anything.
Hi, I'm family stuff.
How much of your power is stored in your Ahuge?
Much, much, much of my power.
So don't ever forget it.
this can't yeah that's stuck there oh you're one minute old
there's like a a brain rot video of uh oh my gosh what's his
name howie he did like deal or no deal the bald man and it's
like some talent show one of those like american idol who's
the most talented person type shows but it's like
And...
Can you, like, edit him?
Yeah, I'm four years old!
And...
And he goes, you're the youngest person ever!
I'm four years old!
Sometimes when people say, like, you are blank years old, I
want to say, I'm four years old!
Meow.
Okay, this is to help us get back up here.
here, clearly.
I'm confused, actually.
Wait, someone helped Grandma out.
What am I supposed to do here?
Oh!
Just kidding!
I made it.
Okay, wait.
I'm scared.
What if I don't make this, though?
Jump!
Ah!
Okay, I understand now.
Forever 19 is too early to be having a mid-afterlife crisis.
I'm four years old!
Oh, wait, uh, I forgot.
I forgot to do the first part.
Wait.
Turn off!
Okay, we're fine.
Okay, we need to lower this first.
Come, come, come, come, come, come, come, come, come.
Like here?
Wait, but it starts to tilt.
It starts to tilt forward.
So I think like a little...
Like here?
You are the youngest VTuber ever!
I'm five years old!
Doesn't go better.
It's slow.
Okay.
Maybe like...
Oh, that's still... Stop, stop.
Maybe like here.
How old is Minto really though?
I'm forever 19!
Okay.
Wait.
Nope.
Jump.
Alright.
Then we also... This is kind of tricky because... Which way
did I push it before?
Was it to the left or to the right?
I'd like...
it perfectly somehow I was a genius hmm whatever let's just
try oh wait uh give me wait give me to the other side no
there will be an attempt oh my gosh wait it's already going
back down I think I missed it you you What is 9 plus 10?
19?
What is this a trick question?
Oh my gosh!
Wait, how?
It's 20!
What?
What is this?
Oh, how did I get it perfectly?
Literally the first time.
I tried both ways!
It's a reference to someone.
What is it?
Like, germa?
I don't know.
Let's try it the other way.
It's that old vine.
Ah!
You youngsters.
Okay.
I wish I had been paying attention before.
Oh, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot!
Okay, my bud.
back up.
Vine does not mix with youngsters.
Um, for grandma it does.
All right, like there, I think.
Maybe like there.
Yeah, yeah, okay.
Why airplane might buy too bad.
Oh no!
I say you do wait!
See you!
Are you flying for Asha Yoru?
That's kind of insane.
So much pressure.
Okay.
Wait, wait, wait.
Don't smush me.
Densetsu mint.
Dent.
High dent.
No!
I come in, dachi!
Okay, okay, that was not ideal, but that's okay.
Okay.
Please, swing it!
Ugh!
I hate physics!
I hate it!
Oh my gosh, gravity never needed to be advantage!
Oh wait, I need to push this first.
Okay, I need to push it this way first.
Okay.
So we can get optimal.
Hooy!
Okay.
Okay, we have the plan now.
Hooy!
First try, Phantom.
Me too cute.
Me too sweet though.
Hmm.
Yeah, you think I'm cute?
Really?
VOD Watchers skip ahead one hour.
Don't say that!
Huh?
Please!
No!
Why did it lose the momentum?
Why?
Oh, no.
Stop being a kid.
Okay.
If only...
If
only...
One more time.
If I watchers, like, subscribe, and hit the bell.
Alright, alright, alright.
Oh.
Jump!
At least I didn't die.
You son of a bitch, why?
My timing.
We know you're cute.
Gotta climb up higher.
I'm literally at the max height!
I can't get any higher!
We can't get much higher!
That's the highest he'll go!
Oh!
It's the switch screws it up.
Okay, I see it now.
I need to propose to you.
Hold that.
Wait, what?
Huh?
I didn't get your meat and green.
So I did get dokeys.
Meet the very cute and spooky.
I can't tell if I need to do the switch sooner or maybe...
Shit!
Oh!
What if I had missed?
Oh, shoot.
I have to stand here.
I'm not even secured.
Oh my god, it was a checkpoint!
Okay, we're gaming.
Oh, blessed checkpoint.
Blessed checkpoint, for real.
Oh!
Oh my gosh, wait.
Oh,
I tried jumping.
Wait, okay, hold on.
I think I gotta jump.
Rage game, rage game.
Ah, oh, he like...
Okay, he, like, won't jump because he's too busy climbing
up.
Maybe I just...
Dangle.
Nope.
Okay, no dangling.
No dangling.
Jump!
Oh, it's still on!
What?
Oh.
Um.
Huh.
But now what?
What if I...
Just put you right?
Who invented this button?
Wait, what?
I don't understand how I could do it, though.
Yeah, the other track is still on, too.
Wait, if I press this, does that other track turn off?
It does not.
Okay.
Interesting.
But I still don't understand what I'm supposed to do about
it, you know?
I guess if I...
What?
Run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run,
run, run, run, run, run, run, run, It's such a four
platform.
It's such a four platform, though.
What?
Yeah, there's not enough time.
Elf, friend.
Thank you so much for the five good.
Thank you.
No, elf.
Listen here.
Grandma is tired.
At least you have less momentum here, so it's a little less
fast,
but...
Oh, whoops.
It's so far away, right?
I feel like it has to be pixel perfect.
Unless maybe I don't... I don't know.
Like I get it to the very, very edge.
Less momentum at the start?
I don't know.
What if it's like here?
Will it roll down slower?
Oh!
I... Oh!
Stop!
Okay.
Yeah, we need it to be like really slow.
Like super slow.
Like this slow.
Stop!
Oh my god.
Snail's pace.
Oh, but it gets faster.
The idea is there, but you need it to be fast.
Wait.
Oh!
Oh, it bounced twice.
Wait, like that?
Like kind of...
It presses and then...
Like, let's go?
Oh, oops.
No, bad.
Well, this is fine because...
Oh, I tried jumping.
I don't think it's enough time, though, no?
I don't think so.
I don't think it's the bounce either.
Yeah, it doesn't, it doesn't, like, let go enough.
It's too short of a gap, yeah.
I think this...
What?
How slow?
Can I get it to be, you know?
I don't feel like I'm getting any further.
Small studio in Copenhagen.
Oh, oh, oh, oops, oops.
A hit.
And a hit.
I wonder if I...
Hold it from the...
If it's like here, you know, let's see.
I'm going to see how slow it goes.
Well, that's kind of hard to tell because I'm still
technically pushing it.
I'm not making any progress at all.
He used
to be going to the left a little bit.
Oh, wait.
Oh, oh.
Oh.
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god!
Oh!
I discovered something new!
Wait,
that's insane, it's so good.
Imagine if I was still there.
Oh!
wait a second I think I screwed myself wait oh never mind
we're fine holy okay I wish I could see anything though it's
kind of bad I think I take you
do I go up or down easy toes thank you so much for the thank
you thank you thank you thank you and maybe I can drop onto
that Now,
go this way, check it out.
Is that the light?
Or are those headlights?
Those are lasers.
Wait, those are lasers.
That's how my grandparents went to school.
Thank you so much, motherfucker.
Let's see what happens if I touch them.
understandable wait can I not get back up I just realized I
guess I was supposed to go down here but can I grab this guy
for assistance no I guess I was supposed to go down here
then I think maybe I can jump oh not like that
okay Let's try.
Oh, oh, they don't stop.
Let's...
What if I jump downstairs?
There is no downstairs.
Oh my gosh.
I'm so bad.
There's no cooldown, it seems, either.
I mean, think of...
Thinko?
I just woke up.
I'm five years old!
Running during the wind down.
Yeah, but...
I guess... Yeah, let's try that.
Ah!
Why do I play Thinkie game today and tomorrow?
The top gun moved.
Top gun.
I think the trick is to get them to shoot simultaneously.
Hey, why didn't the other one activate?
Oh.
Oh!
Do I have to destroy this one?
Oh, wait.
Oh, it's starting to bleed.
It's starting to bleed.
Come on.
Yes.
Good, good, good.
The music stopped.
I broke the CD player, I think.
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
Very good.
Is this...
Are those...
Is that...
A trap?
Why is it lumpy on the floor?
Just lumps.
Okay, we do parkour.
for real.
What's this button do?
Oh, interesting.
Oh, gosh.
This one.
Oh, no.
Why did we invent gravity?
Why did we do that?
Seriously, why did we do that?
I think I need...
Okay.
need I feel like I need one of the boxes to like slide down
or something like I push one of the boxes to time it to
slide and then that this so this one and then the other box
will go up there wait but how would I get up there how
would I get back up here
let me just for now try my plan
oh oh I think this guy needs to be already pushed over here.
I screwed up, I think.
There we go.
Uh, and then once he drops, I grab him.
Maybe?
Grab him, grab him, grab!
There we go.
Nice.
I figured it out.
Hoi!
Oh my gosh, a puzzle that doesn't kill me.
I think, though, if they...
I think if they landed on me, though, they would have killed
me.
Where did this go?
Oh, what?
Wait, what?
Hmm?
Where do I need to go?
I can't tell.
Oh my gosh, wait.
Do I have to do the same thing, but with the ladder?
Jump.
The
ladder would push back up.
Oh.
I thought the ladder would push back up.
Oh my gosh, Immortal Flame.
Thank you so much for that.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
Oh, okay.
I pretend you would have hit the ceiling.
Well, I didn't think about that.
I guess I could grab this block from over here.
Okay, maybe.
Hopefully it lifts up.
All right, let's do that again.
Oh my gosh, wait, the window of opportunity here is like
actually so small.
Run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run,
run, run, run, run, run,
okay one more time okay and then i think i have to like be
on here when it lifts because otherwise i cannot uh grab
that so it's gonna lift me up baby and then we go go go okay
we almost got boxed for real me when i'm like wow i'm
surprised it's a puzzle that doesn't Kill me!
Okay.
Run, run, run, run, run, run.
Run, run, run, run, climb, climb, climb, climb, climb,
climb.
Climb, climb, climb, climb, climb.
Run, run, run, run, run, climb, climb, climb, climb, climb.
Whoa!
We made it.
Whenever I was saying run, run, run, run, climb, climb,
climb, climb.
Do you guys remember that episode of the Powerpuff Girls
where they were watching?
the TV Mojo Jojo was was babysitting them and they're
watching the TV and the it's like the the sea serpent guy
Blarney the sea serpent whatever I don't remember and he's
just like if I were a fish I'd scream scream that's what I
was thinking holy nostalgia this is the elevator oh does
it go up any higher No.
Okay.
Mysterious tanking box.
Oh!
That is a laser.
Oh my gosh.
It's so hard to see it, though.
That's another laser.
Can I get on top of this?
I can get on top of this, though.
Oh!
My bad.
I knew that was coming.
I don't know why.
I just stood there and took it.
I was like, I can tank it.
I can tank it is what I said.
I don't know if I got shot, but I know that.
I literally just like, bonk.
Bounced off my head.
Okay, okay.
Now with this, does it block the bullets?
Oh.
Wait a second.
Oh my god.
I was like, why is that hole there?
Wow, environmental storytelling is crazy.
Okay.
Environmental storytelling goes crazy!
What is this now?
It's just a...
A wall that goes back and forth.
Very cool.
I didn't realize we were...
Playing Portal all of a sudden, you know?
With all these turrets.
I think I have to be...
Well, what else is over here?
Trees.
Monkeys?
Oh, wait.
Oh, dang it.
I didn't realize that I wouldn't be able...
Wait.
Paul?
How do you do this?
Oh, I think I have to land...
Okay, I get it.
I get it.
I have to land...
on it.
Unmute.
Okay, okay.
I got it.
Environmental storytelling is a poem when there's no
dialogue.
True, so true.
Oh, but...
How do I fall?
Laser sees boy triggers gun.
Laser sees box and goes, It's a box.
Yeah.
Maybe it's a heat-seeking laser.
Anything to the far left.
Oh, good point.
I didn't explore over here.
Why is there grass on the side?
ceiling anyway.
There's a butterfly.
Can I even get up there?
Maybe with the box?
It's mold.
New avant-garde grass on ceiling.
Gardner was Australian.
Probably actually.
Keep on pushing.
I don't even think I'll make it with the box though.
No!
How...
Do I get to the other side?
Or...
Like...
Maybe I have to be the speediest person.
What?
No.
I don't know.
Like...
So basically my dilemma is...
I...
say I push this box here.
Like...
here for
it to be on this thing how
do I get up here you know that's my dilemma
yeah I need two boxes but I only have one but
where would I even get the other one I
don't see anything else around here I tried like grabbing
here just in something behind the tree, but I don't.
Nothing gets caught.
There was one downstairs, was there?
Wait, was there actually?
Did I miss it?
Come.
Go down, go fast, fast, fast, fast, fast, fast, fast, fast,
fast, fast, fast, fast, fast, fast, fast, fast, fast.
Oh, no!
Wait, we don't have my box!
Anymore?
It was that one.
Oh.
Yeah, this one's a thinker.
This one's a head scratcher.
Use the box to block the gun on top of the elevator.
But that doesn't...
I don't think that'll solve my problem.
Will it?
Was there another...
Because...
I don't think that'll...
Will that?
I mean, at this point, I have no other, I have no other
ideas, so...
We shall attempt...
But I don't even know where it was.
Yeah, can't hurt, that's true.
It could just be a big old waste of my time!
No, just kidding.
Is it...
What if I... right here?
Wait.
Oh, wait.
Uh...
the gun if I put it on the elevator it'll block it
right kind of get it smack dab in the middle there maybe
nope redo why'd they make it so far away it might have
bounced off you think so?
Let's do like there.
Run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run.
I think I still see it.
Woo!
I don't think I'll be able to make it back, but I just want
to see, uh, maybe...
Where'd my box go?
Where is it?
Secret gauntlet level that's excessive.
by getting all secret collectibles.
Whoa.
Oh, there's my box!
What if I...
What if I'm overthinking it?
What if I just do this?
Oh, but now...
I can't get to...
I can't get back, though.
Wait a second, though.
Wait a second.
Hold on.
Push it a tiny bit.
Tiny bit like that.
Okay.
Alright.
Then maybe.
Jump!
Oh!
What is this?
Another box.
We found it.
Come back to me.
Okay, now we need this bad boy.
Alright, alright.
Where are you going?
To...
What are you talking about?
I'm going to do the thing so that I can get the other box.
She's going to see her mom.
She's a very nice lady.
Where is it?
About to go all the way back there again?
Oh my god.
Let's see why it didn't flip.
Why it didn't come down.
Ugh.
Oh.
Let's see.
Like, how am I You guys are like, where are you going?
But how am I even supposed to get that?
What am I even supposed to do here?
Oh, wait.
Oh, I just noticed that this was controlling.
I thought it, like, activated a thing to drop the box from,
like, a box container.
Eki, look about the key!
What?
I did, too, to be honest.
Yeah, right!
It just came from nowhere!
How the hell am I supposed to do this though?
Damn it.
Not enough.
Wait.
Ah!
No!
Stop rolling the wrong way!
Ah!
Oh, dang it.
I had it in a... Oh, nope, nope, nope, nope.
There we go.
Oh!
So close!
No!
Oh, not enough.
Get it back up there.
Rotate that box!
Oh, oh, my bad.
Oh, oh my god.
Came in, coming in hot.
Coming in hot.
Oh, dang it!
Yay!
Okay!
Now it should be good.
When we...
Alright.
Come back.
Yeah, we'll just...
First try, Phantom.
And,
and, and, and... Dusty, thank you so much for the tangata!
Thank you!
Thank you so much.
Okay.
On the road again.
Wait, why'd you do that?
Oh my god, don't scare me.
Don't scare me like that.
You stay here.
Second trusty box.
Second...
Trusty box.
Alright, now here...
This is where it's gonna be all about timing.
How do I...
No, the timing is like, imperative here.
It's a good thing I'm a cat because I love boxes.
I wonder if this would do it.
I don't think so, though.
I don't think so.
Run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run.
Run, run, run, run, run.
Shit didn't believe.
First try!
More gravity!
That's a big boy.
That thing will surely kill me.
What's this?
Okay.
What if we gravity with the magnet?
What else is going on in here?
I'm just pressing buttons.
Do I need that rope?
Oh, this thing also lifted up.
Interesting.
I don't even know how to get up there though.
Parkour.
This one's a bit funky, is it?
You can jump onto the left platform.
Can I now?
I, wait, why am I not?
If I, I can hide there, that's one thing.
Oh wait, does this turn it off?
That is, in fact, not a rope.
How am I supposed to turn it off?
Like, what is this rope for?
Okay.
I guess just for power?
One block is shorter.
What do you mean by that?
You remember it now?
I do see that this one is sticking up over the edge.
If I go up...
Do I... Oh my gosh.
I don't become... I don't become anti-gravity.
I don't think.
No.
Can you move the big box left and right?
This guy up here?
How can I even push him, though?
That's the thing.
Huh?
What box are you guys talking about?
Stick left box.
Not right box.
What?
You guys are trying to help, but I'm too stupid to
understand your hints.
Need to magnet the left one, but not the right one.
When I magnet, it does both of them.
It's not like a left or right issue.
Grab off, mag off.
Mag on.
Then quickly grab off.
Grab off.
Mag off.
Then quickly.
there's a delay before the fall yeah but it's still really
fast no wait if i but
to like push this i want to train now and there's a ghost
sitting next to me oh bring her as my plus one like you're
bringing another ghost to me me guys
i think i'm too brain dead to understand this one
like i i get what you guys are saying but i don't understand
it
brain rot i definitely said brain dead i think you have the
brain rot i think your brain is rotting i mean my brain is
rotting in other ways because my body is probably buried in
the somewhere.
My brain is already rotted.
Fiddle with grab.
Okay.
Wait, if I have the magnet on, there's no way for me to
fiddle with the gravity though.
Uh.
Think of how much distance each box has to travel.
Need it to fall?
I don't understand what you guys are saying at all.
You guys are literally speaking like a different language to
me right now.
You guys are like definitely...
You guys are like speaking another language.
You could be...
You could literally be saying...
You were saying English, but it looks like Chinese to me.
Magnets, how do they work?
Seriously!
I'm literally...
Those guys right now!
Put me in clown makeup right now!
Like It's just They're so far away That I have to press
these So I'm like so confused
And when I do this It's still stuck So I don't understand
Magnet on Then grab on for a second Then off right away Yeah
but with the magnet on They just stay up Yeah That's why I'm
so confused.
You say grab on off, but they don't do it.
It doesn't change anything.
That's why I'm confused.
Start with the boxes on the ground.
And then I do the magnet on.
And then I mess with the gravity.
Is that what I do?
Step one, both off.
Step two, magnet on.
Step three, turn grab on and off real quick.
My left unsealing.
Wait, my left is unsealing, but before right gets there.
How much time do I even have, then?
It's like the shortest amount of time.
Wait, because I need to jump onto this.
It's like boo-boo.
Oh!
I heard it.
Holy moly.
I thought...
Here's where my brain was like...
When you guys were like, you need to push the boxes or
whatever.
I was like, so I need to like turn this on and off so that
it like slightly shifts over so that I can come up here.
I was like, there's this gap over here.
So I thought I needed to be in the gap for some reason.
And I was like, I need to push this box up.
I needed to fit I was like wow how do I physically push that
box I'm just a weak kid I was like that seems like a really
heavy box how am I supposed to push it what's going on here
is that a lighthouse oh thank you guys I seriously don't
think I would have gotten it oh nothing gonna kill me or
okay
No!
Go back!
Grab it!
Okay, I get this one too.
We have to have it like swinging towards me.
Uh...
Nope.
No,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Okay.
He was like two...
Two little fingers away!
Oh wait, I think I didn't do it.
Nope.
I didn't, I knew it, but I still tried for it.
It's fine because this was pretty easy to just...
Do over and over.
Yeah, we got this one.
Oh, whoops, whoops, whoops, whoops.
Oh, but the momentum.
Come on, come on.
So close every time.
I know.
Grab it!
Oh, ee.
This kid's got to work out.
I think we said the same exact thing last time.
We said this kid.
No.
Wait.
Oh, shoot.
I gotta let it go.
Come on, come on.
It messes with your head, like the perspective.
And, oh my God, please.
Yes!
Ah!
I didn't see the spikes.
Oh
my god, now it's going to be another 10 years before I can
grab it again.
Oh.
Please.
Really stuck that landing.
Thank you.
Did I just die?
Is it that rope that's down there?
Rope?
That?
Wait.
They caught it saved here.
I know.
The game.
is pretty forgiving in that regard i suppose wait the sign i
saw it but
all it says is right there's a button wait where do you guys
see the button
Oh, the sign is a button.
Oh.
Oh, my God.
This one's going to be hellish.
Wait, this is terrifying.
Wait.
Oh, no.
Did I get electrocuted?
No way.
I thought I missed it.
Oh, please!
Okay.
Hey, where do I go from here though?
Maybe I fall back onto the sign?
Oh, I see!
There we go.
Okay, okay, okay.
I saw it.
Oh!
Okay, okay.
Alright, alright.
I wasn't completely blind.
I wasn't completely blind this time.
Wait, why did I do that?
Okay, uh, kid?
She got a little confused, everybody.
Oh, I pressed the wrong button.
My button.
That's me.
That's me pressing jump instead of use.
Oh, that was too early.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh!
We're okay!
Everything's fine.
Literal pinky toe.
Alright.
Okay, okay.
Okay.
Woo, we got it.
We're fine.
Everything's okay.
Everything's cool.
Everything's fine.
All right.
What could go wrong?
Nothing.
So why all of a sudden...
Oh, this one has a timer?
Okay.
If I fall, I die.
Alright.
Where do I bring you?
What do I do with you?
Oh, wait.
I think I know what to do.
Wait.
Huh?
Oh.
I pressed the wrong button.
I go.
Stop torturing this poor boy.
He should have...
Man, I really should have paid attention and jam.
Wait, please.
Oh my gosh.
It's like...
We're going to get smushed in.
Oh, whoops.
You can't move when you're dropping.
That's so mean.
I was going to try and, like, press it again.
Okay, okay.
Oh!
You have to do it three times, maybe?
Might be a three-pressor.
I think so.
Holy cow.
Holy!
I feel like we were so close.
My bad.
No, I have to start over.
Evil!
Evil game!
Wait.
I'm stupid.
Oh, I messed up already.
Team.
It's over.
It's so over for us.
Okay.
I don't know if I'll make this one either.
I made it.
Okay.
Wait, wait, wait!
Oh, okay.
We're fine.
Maybe?
What is that all the way over there?
There's like something here.
What is this?
Oh, shit.
Thank you, checkpoint.
For real, though.
Checkpoint's a real one.
Look at it.
Wait, I timed.
I mistimed it again.
Okay, okay.
Yeah, the timer is the BGM.
Lock in.
I'm trying.
Oh, wait.
Oh, please.
Wait.
Oh, how do I do this?
Wait, how do I do this?
I think right before.
Oh, it almost saved me.
Oh.
You can't, like, move while you're falling, so it's kind of
tricky.
Got it.
Oh, shit.
Ow.
Damn it!
Why didn't I go forward?
I'm so stupid.
Oh, okay, though.
It put me back here.
Okay.
Run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run.
Oh!
Okay, I have to jump there.
Okay, got it.
Oh
my god.
This part's so intense!
Oh!
Ouch!
Hit!
Oh, come on!
This game!
Are you for real?
No, stinking way.
Oh my god.
How the hell?
Wait.
What?
What is this?
It's okay if we really...
Can I even keep going this way?
I just wanted to try.
I didn't think I would make it, but...
It just keeps, I guess.
I tried to undo it.
I tried to click fast.
Gotta shoot the whoop?
I'm a fire in my body!
Oh!
Did I make it?
First try?
Oh my god, am I dead?
Please, no.
Imagine it's just like, okay, do it all over again.
Does the cutscene, but I actually died.
Do a flute.
Wait, what is over here now?
Was that like the glass that I broke through?
Was that like the windshield of a car or something?
That's why I'm in limbo.
I died in a car accident.
That's how I'm finally getting out of aperture science.
Thank you.
Oh, the little girl.
We need MatPat.
Hello.
Well, I say little girl, but...
Is that her hair or...
Okay, that's her hair.
Oh.
Okay.
That's it?
She has a theory.
That's my theory.
Yeah!
Wait!
You guys!
I beat the game!
Wait!
I for some reason thought I had like another four hours of
this game.
A mint theory.
That's my theory.
I thought we were gonna like see a car or something.
And it'd be like, That's where I died.
Oh my god.
William C.
Thank you so much for the podcast.
Thank you.
There's always inside.
Is that the sequel?
Another one added to the completed list.
Yeah!
I didn't think I would...
It had done so fast.
Let's go!
It's very similar, but it's not a direct sequel.
Oh, got it.
Oh, where credit is due.
its own reward.
What are the chapters?
Oh, I like the spider, though.
The spider is so detailed.
That's the thing about this game, too, is so detailed.
Congrats on beating the game.
Big brain ghost made gamer.
There was that one puzzle that I absolutely did not
understand at all, that you guys helped me with but i feel
like i got everything else myself you can't win them all i
could never beat this game thank you for closure whoa thank
you eggie ben welcome back dorko thank you so much for the
pig it's totally unprepared for it to end there i know me
too master timing and gravity gravity doing gravity felt
like half-life again
Kodena, I think you're so much with the pod, good dude.
How is she so good?
Some of the puzzles stumped me for a while.
Yeah, if I didn't have you guys, I'd be like...
I'd be...
I'd just be sitting here like this, like...
So...
Thank you for helping me out.
Thank you, thank you.
I was seeing the bodies in the river was creepy.
We're no more freaky kids, though.
At least I saved Granny for her dementia, but keeping her
brain short.
I would say I lived to see another day, but I'm already
gone.
My brain...
Oh, this one?
I hated this one.
This bug and trying to get that guy hated that part.
We started.
We started...
Here...
No.
I guess technically here?
It was like right after this, no?
Right before the cart.
Yeah, for some reason it doesn't show in it.
Maybe it's a different chapter.
So right in between here.
So I had like the littlest bit of the game left.
there's an achievement where you need to beat the game
without dying more than five times well imagine if i got
that first try that would be crazy i don't think you can
though well not to say that you can't but like some of them
some of these you need to die to know what to do congrats me
though to complete the game despite all the death count it
was great i'm happy for a great boss thank you thank you
some of you have to die to know how to complete the puzzle
so they use dying as a teaching tool yeah so if you've never
played the game before of course you're gonna die a ton
congrats thank you oh my gosh qp 0 a l 0 z m 0 0 0 rf thank
you there's a well-known bug that causes the game to freeze
just as you pass through the barrier at the end which is
super annoying oh my gosh that would have been horrible but
at the same time what it's like go go youtube the ending
what's the ending
I used to be able to one CC this, Dad, I could do it now.
That's crazy.
But yeah, thank you guys for the help through some of these
puzzles.
I do appreciate it, I do, but we are a team.
So thank you very much.
What are you talking about?
You beat it for a try.
Yeah!
God gamer!
It was fun, though.
It was really fun.
Like, it was just...
The game is very forgiving.
In that, like, there's many, many checkpoints.
Usually.
There were some points.
I think there were some parts, especially in part one, that
I was like, I have to do all of this over again.
But, for the most part, it was pretty forgiving.
And...
I...
Honorary Druid.
Yeah, I think the checkpoints were well placed.
Yeah.
few mean checkpoints yeah just a couple mean ones but most
of them are not so bad um especially towards the end they're
like we know this part was annoying you don't have to do it
again it's all right um but i think the puzzles a lot of
them uh some of them were like really like oh my gosh my
brain is not expanded enough for this but some of them were
like really clever so i like that
Where it was like a rage game, but not at the same time.
Oh my gosh, I want to play Celeste.
I feel like I could become a real gamer if I like actually
beat Celeste.
They were counting how many playtesters broke down in tears?
Why?
Celeste is a gamer's game.
I know!
I feel like if I beat Celeste, I'd be able to be like, yeah,
I did it.
I'm a gamer now, I'm a gamer.
That, Celeste is like, I'm going to say it.
Celeste is the Dark Souls of Platform.
No, just kidding.
Oh, arachnophobia, amazing.
If you really are unsettled by spiders, this game is not
good.
so courageous.
I say what the people are afraid to speak out loud.
Jump King?
No, that's a real rage game.
That's a real rage game.
Just played Lego Island and got kicked twice by the skeleton
in the race.
I love... Robo, no!
No!
The spider seemed oddly cute, though.
I think they made it more like like a black widow spider if
it looked like a tarantula spider it would have been very
cute do you guys understand what I mean
no yes yeah tarantulas have like thicker thicker leggies and
they're very fuzzy and cute they're like they have like
thicker these ones are like very thin and like they remind
me of the They're very, like, creepy, crawly.
But, yeah, more chonka and fuzz.
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
Tarantulas are very cute.
But these guys were, like, very, like...
They, like, sound...
Like, if they...
If you could hear them, they sound like they would, like,
creak and crack.
You know what I mean?
I tolerate spiders more than roaches and centipedes.
Oh, I hate roaches.
Guckiburi, yada.
and Matorakan yeah spiders it depends on the spider for me I
suppose you know when I was a wee wisp though I loved like
playing with daddy long legs and stuff so I don't know I
don't like the spiders that jump but there's like a type of
jumping spider that is very cute when you like watch videos
of it I love that one but if I saw that they're like very
small right I don't like the small, jumpy ones that kind of
like lunge at you, you know, and like move erratically.
How many more games for your goal before the month is over?
Let's see, let's see.
Let's see.
How many more games I need to complete before the month is
over?
Another for the list.
Want to decide my potluck fate tomorrow.
Should I subject my friends to Italian seafood or cookies?
Italian.
Oh.
Because I want to be there.
Oh, wait.
I beat Lego Island yesterday.
Hold on.
I'm counting it.
I'm counting Lego Island.
And then 12, 13, 2025.
Seven more games.
We'll have missed.
But I probably, I don't think I'll beat it tomorrow.
But who knows, I might be super brained.
I have missed.
And then Barry and I will be finishing Battle Blades.
uh not next week i think then a week after
so those are two more games i'll have as well so then after
that i think it's five yeah
yeah so chat's gonna be rough tomorrow uh it's okay that's
all good
we'll we'll we'll be okay we'll be okay gonna have to find
some short games i might have to like double up and do like
two games in one or something you have the rest of the games
you want to beat not really there's like a couple there was
like um one horror game i think it was like amanda the
adventurer i had on my list um since i heard that one was
pretty short and also
that harma john sausage garlic bread wait that sounds
amazing
It's got three games.
Yeah, but the first one would be...
is pretty short.
I could always do the other two another time.
Anonymous Agony.
I don't even know what that is.
This is the song I used to fall asleep to for many years.
It's pretty relaxing.
But I'll figure... I'll figure out some games.
FNAF!
No FNAF.
No, no FNAF.
I'll figure it out.
There's still many recommendations that people gave to me
already.
So, um...
And if not, I'll just play things that I...
want to play.
Like, kind of how I did with Last Report and stuff like
that.
So...
I missed Minto Cafe Shenan again.
So here is the Apollo Super Chat.
Oh, Jeffrey!
Don't even worry about it.
Yu-Tai-san, thank you!
Oh, Kairi.
But yeah, I guess it's a shorter stream today, but that's
fine.
I have some things I need to do before...
before...
before I have cafe stuff tonight.
So this is good.
Anonymous Agni is ironically crazier than Mystery of the
Druids.
similar vein of nutty I do love me some nutty games I do
love me a nutty game I really thought I was gonna be done at
like crazy time oh I'm I'm feeling a little more relieved I
thought I would have to go like up until my cafe awesome
appearance tonight thanks for the stream God gamer me those
gaming brain grew through sizes today yeah thank you try
princess thank you everybody Thank you so much for joining
me again.
And I will see you when I see you next.
Otumito!
Otumito, otumito.
Despite the game you'll choose, it's okay.
Whatever, you will have fun.
How does one survive such cuteness?